la guerre de communication se poursuit
autour de la centrale de zaporizhya ce
lundi moscou a de nouveau attribué à
l'ukraine les attaques qui ont récemment
touché la centrale
le 7 août le régime delhaize qui a
commis un nouvel acte de terrorisme
nucléaire contre les installations de la
centrale nucléaire afin de créer une
catastrophe humanitaire dans la région
de kherson et deux à porridge à
des accusations réfutées en bloc par les
autorités ukrainiennes selon kiev ce
sont les forces russes qui bombarde la
centrale ce week end ces frappes ont
endommagé de nombreuses lignes
électriques situés autour du site depuis
début mars la centrale de zaporizhya
sous contrôle de l'armée russe continue
à fournir de l'électricité grâce à des
employés de la société ukrainienne
energo atom une situation intenable pour
son président qui a appelé à agir alors
que les risques d'incendié et de rejet
radioactif grandissent de jour en jour
nous constatons que les dangers pour la
sécurité nucléaire sont importants nous
pensons que pour assurer la sécurité de
la centrale nucléaire des apories djia
la meilleure décision et le retrait des
envahisseurs et l'établissement d'une
zone démilitarisée de 5 km autour du
site naples est votre père m ce pari ce
qu'attendait staff energoatom plaide
notamment pour une intervention des
experts de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique un scénario qui a peu
de chance de devenir selon de nombreux
observateurs la russie profite du danger
qu'ils représentent la centrale pour
lancer des opérations militaires ce
lundi les autorités nommé par moscou
dans la région de zaporijia ont lancé
les préparatifs d'un référendum pour
permettre à la province de rallier la
fédération de russie